Okay, welcome back. Welcome to video
number 18. Now, we've covered all the
leading indicators at the worldview level
in the investment process. Now, we're
going to go to the next level in the stock
market, which is at the industry level,
and we're going to start considering
industries and even go as far as
considering stock markets.
stocks when we get further down the line.
Now, bear in mind, we haven't even looked
at a stock yet. We've basically gone
through the process of formalizing our
worldview. And in the stock markets, the
next thing we do is go to the industry
level, and you're going to be introduced
to a number of new concepts that you may
not have seen before. Probably the most
important concept here is really the
concept of taking the least amount of risk
possible.
possible to get the highest amount of
return. We've mentioned this in previous
videos. And this concept as traders,
because the world has just got so much
information in it. This concept of doing
the least amount of work possible, as in
focusing on what's really, really
important, doing the least amount of work
possible to get the highest amount of
return with the least amount of risk.
This is something I really want you to
focus on when we're going through this
video. Now, you're going to be introduced
to the concept of beta and alpha. And beta
really is the concept of the market
return, and how we hedge out market risk.
So how do we get a higher return, but on
the journey of getting that higher return,
essentially taking less risk.
to get the higher return. That's how you
become an efficient trader. So doing the
least amount of work possible to get the
highest amount of return with the least
amount of risk. And understanding the
concept of beta and alpha. You're also
going to be introduced to new different
types of trades. Now these different types
of trades are trades in which their
structure means we're applying this
principle.
So you'll be introduced to new and the top
down process. So you'll be introduced to
these trades. And the top down process
really going from the world view to the
industry view to the stock view really has
a foundation in these principles and you
need to understand them.
And in terms of doing the least amount of
work possible. And in terms of doing the
least amount of work possible, you're
going to, from your worldview, enter this
stage having a predisposition. So for
example, if you believe that global GDP is
going to increase dramatically, your
predisposition is going to be bullish on
the stock market.
that have earnings which are more
sensitive to the business cycle. So you're
going to be looking to go along these
sectors. And these sectors are called
cyclicals. And your predisposition is
going to be moving away from what we call
defensives. Defensive sectors.
Defensive sectors. As in sectors in the
stock market whose earnings are much less
sensitive to the business cycle, if at
all. So you can go long cyclicals and
short defensives. And if your view is vice
versa, you're going to go short cyclicals
and long defensives. So if your view is
negative on global GDP.
So let's go into the presentation. Try to
understand these new concepts. And I'll
see you for a summary at the end of the
presentation. What we're also going to do
is go on the computer screen. And I'm
going to show you how to build out trade
ideas using Excel at the industry level.
Let's go over to the stage. And I'll see
you at the end of this video for a
summary. And the review.
So let's move down to the industry level.
When we get to this level, we assume that
we have achieved a worldview. Like I said,
the process is as important as getting the
answer. You guys have to keep practicing
going through the process. So at this
point, we assume that we've obtained a
worldview. So we've gone through all the
PMIs in the US.
Consumer sentiment indicators. Done the
same in Europe. Done the same in China.
And we've now established our view on the
world. So what does that mean? We've
established a view on cyclical and
defensive commodities, currencies, and
rates and bonds.
And now if we're going to go further in
the stock market, we have to drill down
from the top to the next level, the
industry level, and then to the bottom,
the stock level.
So that's where we're going to be
positioned for the next chapter at the
industry level. And in any market, any
stock market, just keep it simple. Within
the market, there's industry sectors. And
within those sectors, there's stocks that
are going to outperform and stocks that
are going to underperform the sector and
or the market.
And this is how you should display your
own mind map when you're looking at the
stock market as a trader. So if you have a
view on GDP that you want to be long the
market, you're going to be looking for
sectors that are going to outperform the
market.
Otherwise, there's no point in owning that
sector. You might as well just own the
market. So if the market's up 18% and you
go and buy a sector thinking it's going to
outperform and it underperforms the market
by 5%, what's happened? You've
underperformed the market. You might as
well have just owned the index.
So it's dead money in that sector.
And then you're going to be looking for
stocks that you think are going to
outperform both the sector and the market.
And the same on the short side.
Everything in the middle is dead money.
You might as well have owned the market or
shorted the market or even done the same
in commodities, currencies or rates.
We try to avoid the dead money situation,
which is owning sectors and stocks or
shorting sectors and stocks that money
would have performed better if we just
represented our view by having a position
in the index.
Now at the industry level, you can map
what we call the value chain onto pretty
much any industry in the world.
So some sort of commodity is processed,
turned into a product by a manufacturer,
which is sold onto a wholesaler.
The wholesaler sells it onto a retailer,
who sells it onto a consumer.
And value is created along the chain.
So a commodity is pulled out the ground
for a dollar.
That commodity is processed by a
manufacturer into a product for $2.
Sold onto the wholesaler for $3.
Wholesaler sells it to retailer for $4.
Retailer sells it to consumer for $10.
And value is created along the chain from
nothing.
That's the value chain.
And that can be mapped onto any industry
in the world.
And you can pull up a sector.
This is a process that you've got to go
through and just practice it.
You pull up a sector.
Let's say, for example, like the
pan-European telecom sector.
And you pull up the US telecom sector.
And you map along the chain where all of
the companies within that sector lie.
What do they actually do?
And where do trade ideas come from?
Well, you get your trade ideas initially
from your macroeconomic analysis.
That will generate ideas for you.
We've seen that.
You can get your ideas from the ISM.
Get ideas from non-manufacturing index.
You get ideas from the European PMIs in
various sectors, various countries.
But then when you drill down, you also get
them at the micro level by analysing the
value chain.
And there'll be demand and supply factors
that affect the value chain.
So if there's a supply shock, it'll take
time to hit the retailer.
If there's a demand shock, it will take
time to hit the manufacturer.
But if you map all of the companies out
and you see the shocks coming, the
unexpected moves,
you'll know where the trades are that are
going to make you money.
Because the trades will always be in the
non-obvious trades.
So there's a supply shock and it takes
time to hit the retailer.
The trade might not be with the
manufacturer because that's known already
right now.
The trade could be to short the retailer
that is affected six months from now.
And you can go short the retailer.
If there's a demand problem, it might not
hit the manufacturer for six months.
You can go short the manufacturer.
That's where you'll get most of your
return, when you drill down from the top
to the industry and the stock level.
But very simply, all sectors can be either
split into cyclicals and defensives.
So when you look at the S&P 500 index, 250
to 300 stocks can be classed as cyclical.
And the rest can be classed as defensive.
So if we think GDP is going up, what's our
bias going to lean towards to be long in
the market?
What type of sectors?
Obvious.
And if we think there's going to be
contraction in the US, Europe, China in
GDP,
what are we going to be leaning towards to
be long?
Defensives.
And you can actually, there's actually
industry classifications for sectors
across the US and Europe.
So in the US, they're called the GICS, the
GICS sectors.
And in Europe, the sectors are split up by
stocks, S-T-O-X-X, as in the Euro stocks,
600 sectors.
Yeah.
And there's real classifications for them.
And you can trade them as a product.
You can trade them on ETF and on CFD.
So cyclicals in the US, the
classifications are much broader.
And then you've got sub-sectors within the
super sectors.
So these are called super sectors.
Energy, materials, industrials, consumer
discretionary, financials and IT.
In Europe, autos and parts, banks, oil and
gas sectors, mining, metals, chemicals,
construction, financials, industrials,
media, personal goods, real estate,
retailers, tech, travel and leisure.
Defensives, in the US, staples.
What do we mean by staples?
Necessity goods.
Healthcare, telco services and utilities.
In Europe, aerospace, food, beverages,
pharma and biotech, telcos, utilities.
Utilities split into electricity, gas and
water.
So let's assume that we've had, we've got,
we're in a situation and it's somewhere
between say March and July 2009.
And we've seen the PMIs globally trough.
They've started contracting slower for the
first time.
So we're starting to lean towards a long
bias in the market because we think GDP
could actually be expanding in the future.
The ISM might go back above 50.
The PMIs have troughed and they're
approaching 50.
Aggressively.
This is an example of how you can go
through the process and work out at the
industry and stock level what trades you
could actually look at.
And we're going to look at the obvious
ones and you'll see the obvious ones still
actually pay ridiculous money if you get
in at the right time.
So what we're looking at here is basically
from March 2009 to around now, how much
these trades have paid here.
So, you're sitting there and you see the
PMIs bottom and you're bullish on the
world.
You're now bullish on GDP.
You think GDP contraction has hit the
bottom because the ISM is literally
telling you it has.
What trades could you have done?
Well, straight away, very obvious with
that world view is the oil price.
Cyclical commodity, GDP expansion, let's
go and buy some oil.
What's that paid since?
170%.
What else could you have done?
Let's say you thought the oil price was
going to double at that stage from $40 to
$80.
What else could you have done?
We could have bought the S&P 500 energy
sector.
That's paid 100%.
And by the way, these are all numbers that
are unleveraged.
So if you were using leverage, you'd get
the multiple of that.
So if you were three or four times
leveraged, you'd be getting in oil 500,
600%, not bad.
The market itself, up 130%.
So what have we seen there straight away?
Oil price up 170.
S&P 500 energy sector up 100.
S&P 500 itself up 130.
What have we seen straight away?
Who's noticed the problem?
Well, a cyclical sector, energy, has
actually underperformed the market.
Why do we think that is?
The answer is, actually, this is something
you'll get to know when you start to
understand the sectors.
So, for example, when you go through that
value chain and you start listing what all
the companies do,
the vast majority of heavyweight oil
stocks in the S&P 500,
they're the big, large cap oil and gas
producers.
And they don't necessarily make money when
the oil price goes up.
Because what happens?
All of these guys rent rigs and platforms,
yeah?
And equipment.
And it's just, it's very specific to the
large cap oil and gas sector.
It's a global situation, global problem
for big, large cap oil and gas companies.
When the oil price goes up 200%, the rents
on the platforms just go up.
And equipment prices go up to drill it.
So, they don't necessarily make as much
money as everybody else when the oil price
goes up.
So, the speed of the earnings growth when
the oil price goes up is a lot lower than
people expect.
So, it's a very obvious trade to go and
buy large cap oil companies when you think
the oil price is going up.
But it's flawed because they might not
necessarily make money.
But you'll get to know that as you start
to understand the idiosyncrasies of each
sector.
Your job is to really, when you start out,
start with a couple of sectors, get to
know them really well,
map them out on the value chain.
Search for trade ideas within cyclicals
and defensives.
And then build up your knowledge across
lots of sectors over the next year or two.
And then you'll become an expert on a
couple and decent on quite a few.
But a few years from now, you'll know a
lot about a lot of sectors.
Because you'll be going through all of the
manufacturing reports, all of the services
reports.
And you'll pick up knowledge along the
way.
So, in that situation, we actually would
have just been better off parking our
money in the index.
Or in the oil price itself.
Or in oil.
So, just try and imagine it from an
investor's perspective.
And you've given money to a really smart
hedge fund manager who markets himself as
the ultimate physical commodities and
global natural resources equities hedge
fund manager.
And in 2009, when he got bullish, which is
good, he parked all your money in the S&P
500 energy sector.
Well, on the surface, you'd all be
high-fiving each other because he's
doubled your money.
But actually, if you'd have given it to
another hedge fund manager who knew about
this, he would have just bought the oil
price.
And you'd be up 170%.
What about if we look at these guys,
Helmrich and Payne, who are onshore and
offshore drilling an exploration company?
They own the rigs and rent them out to all
of the large-cap oil and gas producers.
What do they do?
Every time the oil price goes up 10%, they
add on 10% to the rent of the rigs.
They renegotiate contracts.
And they've got no choice but to pay it.
Because if they don't pay it, their
competitor will just turn up next week and
walk onto the rig and start drilling.
They were up 215% over the same time
period.
So they outperformed the market.
They outperformed the sector by over
double the amount.
And they outperformed the oil price, which
is the only commodity they're exposed to.
So the speed of their earnings goes up a
hell of a lot faster than, for example,
someone like Chevron, Exxon, BP, Royal
Dutch Shell.
These guys make a much quicker return when
the oil price goes up.
And conversely, when it goes down, they
lose money quicker.
So within the sector, within the cyclical
sector, you've got stocks that are more
cyclical than other stocks.
And that's going to be the same across any
sector.
Even in defensives, stocks that are more
defensive than other stocks.
It's where their earnings come from in the
value chain and how sensitive they are to
the business cycle.
In that situation, you'd be all over
Helmrich and Payne because you assume
that, we're assuming here that you've got
your worldview and you know about these
stocks in the sector because you've mapped
them out on the value chain.
And you know the basic idiosyncrasies of
each sector.
What about the consumer discretionary
sector?
The consumer discretionary sector
outperformed the energy sector by double
the amount, over double the amount.
In that situation, there will be stocks.
If the sector's up 215%, there's going to
be stocks in that sector that are up 120%.
There's going to be stocks in that sector
that are up 340%.
The sector is the average return of all
the stocks in it.
What about utilities?
Significantly underperform the market.
Significantly underperform all the
cyclical sectors we've looked at.
So you can see with the price action that
this actually works.
You know, cyclicals really do outperform
by a huge amount defensive sectors when
GDP expands.
And they underperform massively when GDP
contracts.
So you're obviously going to be leaning
towards cyclicals, sectors and stocks when
you believe GDP is going to expand.
And you can see it's not that difficult to
connect the dots.
When you see for the first time the ISM
contraction is slowing for the first time
in over a year.
That's when GDP has bottomed.
GDP contraction has bottomed.
And you should be piling into cyclicals.
And then conversely, when GDP slows,
growth slows for the first time, you need
to be piling into defensives.
And looking to go short cyclicals.
But all based on the premise that you're
going to outperform the sector and the
market.
Otherwise, there's no point.
There's no point.
So I'm sure you all know what beta is, the
market return.
Positive alpha returns over and above
beta.
Negative alpha returns below the market
return, beta.
Your job as a trader, if you're going
through the asset classes, if you trade
all the asset classes,
your job as a trader, if you choose to
take positions in sectors and stocks, is
to outperform the market.
Otherwise, it's dead money.
You might as well have owned the market,
shorted the market.
You might as well have taken a position in
the commodities, currencies or rates.
Because you probably would have got a
higher return for lower risk.
And that's the key.
Your job as a trader in the stock market
is not just to generate alpha, positive
alpha.
But it's also to generate that with the
lowest possible risk.
As traders, you want to go where the money
is.
But you also want to go where the money is
and take the least amount of risk possible
to get it.
That's your job.
So I find it quite hilarious when you, for
example, look online or turn the TV on or
read a newspaper
and you see people creating negative
headlines about hedge funds that have
underperformed the market.
Totally irrelevant.
Because if that hedge fund manager's
mandate is that they're looking for a 12%
return per year
on 8% volatility, it doesn't matter what
the market does.
Because that's why the investors have
given their money to that hedge fund
manager.
So that hedge fund manager is taking less
risk than the rest of the market to get a
certain return.
So if our job as traders is to get the
highest amount of return possible for the
least amount of risk,
there's various structures of trades you
can do to create that situation.
So cross-sector spread trades, where, for
example, you go long the S&P 500 consumer
discretionary sector
and short the utility sector and hedge out
market risk in the process.
So when you hedge out the market risk,
you're taking less risk
to get the returns that the sectors are
going to give you.
Does that make sense?
We'll come on to how you do it, but assume
that you've hedged out one risk
in the list of all the risks that you've
got exposure to, yeah?
Cross-sector constituent spread trades.
So let's go into the consumer
discretionary sector
and pick a stock that we think is going to
massively outperform both the sector and
the market.
So we look at a restaurant stock in the
US, Chipotle Mexican Grill.
So we think their EPS growth is going to
be ridiculous and it's going to outperform
the rest of the sector.
And the sector is going to outperform the
market.
And we go short, Entergy, which is a
utility in the United States, a big $11
billion stock in the United States.
So they are constituents of the consumer
discretionary sector and the utility
sector.
So you think there's going to be a
consumer discretionary stock that will
underperform its sector and underperform
the market as a whole.
And you use that to hedge out risk in
Chipotle Mexican Grill.
So you're hedging out market risk and
sector risk.
Does that make sense?
So you're trying to get paid the highest
possible return for the least amount of
risk.
Now let's go through an example in the UK.
Just so you can try to understand the
approach.
Let's have a look at Long Tesco, Short
Sainsbury's.
That's a classic spread trade within the
retail space in the UK.
So they're both essentially supermarkets.
Now if you'd have put that spread trade on
in 1987, that trade would have paid you
1,300%.
So Tesco outperformed Sainsbury by 1,300%.
The return in Tesco was 1,400%.
The return in Sainsbury's was 100%.
So essentially, you've hedged out in 1987
the risk of the market and the risk of the
sector.
And for 25 years, you don't have that
risk.
So what have you done?
You've paid the performance of Sainsbury,
100%, to obtain the performance of Tesco,
minus that, 1,300%,
to hedge out all of those risks for that
whole amount of time.
So throughout the length of that trade,
let's say you had that trade on for 25
years.
Think of all the stuff that happened in
the market and happened in the world,
where there were market shocks, where the
market dropped 10%, 20%, 30%.
So 1992, the UK being kicked out of the
ERM.
1987, the 87 crash.
The tech bubble bursting, 2000.
September the 11th, 2001.
Asian, Russian debt crisis, 97, 98.
Look at all these things that affect the
overall market.
Now, what happens to your spread trade?
What happens to your trade in that
situation when you're long one stock,
short another in the same sector?
What happens?
Well, if you're well hedged, and you've
hedged out the market risk properly, you
shouldn't expect to make or lose any money
in those situations.
Because they just both go down by the same
amount.
So what are you actually doing in that
trade?
You've hedged out the market risk and the
sector risk.
What happens if there's a problem in the
food supply chain to the UK?
Well, both stocks will be affected.
So they both go down the same amount.
What you're actually doing in that trade,
which is exactly the same trade as long
CMG, Chipotle Mexican grill, short
McDonald's.
What you're actually doing is you're
isolating company risk.
So you're saying, I don't want to be
exposed to the market risk.
I don't want to be exposed to the sector
risk.
I want to isolate unique risk and be
exposed to the corporate plan of CMG or
Tesco relative to McDonald's or Sainsbury.
So you're exposing yourself to the
management earnings plan of each company.
And hedging out those two risks.
So you get 1300% return, long Tesco, short
Sainsbury.
And that's unleveraged.
So imagine if you did that three or four
times leveraged.
You've massively outperformed the stock
market and the sector over 25 years.
Massively.
But for significantly less risk.
Because all the guys who owned the market
in that time were exposed to the 87 crash.
They were exposed to the UK being kicked
out of the ERM.
They were exposed to the Russian-Asian
debt crisis of 97-98.
They were exposed to the tech bubble
bursting.
They were exposed to September the 11th.
They were exposed to the subprime crisis.
In your trade, you were not.
Because they both fell.
So you didn't make or lose any money.
That's what we mean by hedging out the
risk.
Now if you do it for shorter periods of
time,
people get lazy because they think,
I don't need to hedge it out because the
world's fine.
I'm only going to have this trade on for
three months.
But the world's fine.
And then what happens?
There's an earthquake in Japan and you
lose all your money.
Now have a look at Chipotle Mexican Grill
and McDonald's.
What's that trade saying?
Well, you're hedging out market and sector
risk.
But what does that trade actually say?
Well, CMG's operating plan,
they'll put it in front of you.
They've got a fiduciary duty to the market
to tell them what their operating plan is
for the next two, three, five years.
Their operating plan two years ago, even
now,
is to open a certain amount of stores in
Europe,
a certain amount of restaurants in Europe
and the US per month.
So what do you think the stocks look like
relative to each other in the last three
years?
What do you think the stocks look like?
Let's just first go through the risk
profile of each trade.
Cross-sector spread trade.
You're hedging out market risk.
You've got sector risk and you've got
stock risk
because you're exposed to all the stocks
in the sector.
If one of those companies blows up,
you're exposed to that
because you own them in the sector.
They might have a small percentage
contribution
to the overall performance of the sector,
but you've still got that risk.
What about cross-sector constituent spread
trades?
No market risk, sector risk and stock
risk.
What about the two stocks in the same
sector?
No market risk, no sector risk,
but you've got stock risk.
But you know that because you're isolating
that risk.
When you take these trades,
you take them with the knowledge
that what risk you're isolating
and what risk you're exposed to.
So let's have a look at some of these
trades.
Now what you do when you look at these
trades,
they're called spread trades or ratio
trades.
You take the share price or the price of
the asset
that you're looking to go long
and you put that on the top of the ratio.
That's the numerator.
That's the convention when you put these
trades together
to look at them.
So here we've got the S&P 500 consumer
discretionary sector.
Short, S&P 500 utility sector.
So the code for the consumer discretionary
sector in the US
and you can trade it on ETF.
Very, very liquid, very easy.
You can be in and out in minutes.
The code is XLY for consumer
discretionary.
The code for the utility sector is XLU.
And you just take the price of XLY
and divide it by XLU.
And you get a ratio.
Ratio here is 1.36.
So what do we think that looks like since
2009?
Well, you've seen the performances.
That's what it looks like.
So it paid 76% since March 2009.
So that's paid less than the market
and less than the consumer discretionary
sector itself.
Yeah?
But what have you done?
You've actually hedged out market risk.
So you've paid money, the potential
return,
to take less risk.
To get that return.
And what you'll find in the market,
when you take, when you hedge out risk,
your expected return is going to be lower.
The home run trade is when you hedge out
risk
and you actually get a better return
than the market and the sector.
That's the home run trade.
And that's what you should always be
looking for.
So that's an example of you paying more,
you paying to take out the risk.
Cross-sector constituent.
So long CMG, short Entergy Corp.
So longer consumer discretionary stock,
short a US utility stock.
What's the return there?
415% since 2009.
Non-leveraged.
What does it look like?
So you can see the ratio goes from 1
to 4.6 roughly.
That's the ratio going up.
Because that's what you want
when you look at these ratios.
If you're long the asset on the top,
the numerator,
short the asset on the bottom,
the denominator,
what are you looking for?
You're looking for the ratio to go up.
Yeah?
What about long CMG, short McDonald's?
That's paid 194%
over the same period.
That's what it looks like.
So what would you say
is the favourite trade there?
What's the favourite trade
out of all of those?
So what you've just seen there
is an example of paying performance
to hedge out risk,
but you still get performance
with lower risk.
Yeah?
Yeah.
What's the favourite trade?
That one?
Yeah?
You'd be right in saying that one.
Because this one,
you're long the consumer
discretionary sector,
short S&P 500 utilities sector.
you pay
to hedge out
the market risk
and you get 76% return.
Your return's lower than the market
and lower than the sectors themselves.
Yeah?
This one,
you've hedged out market risk
and sector risk
and you've got 194% return.
this one,
you've got 200% return plus
over and above this one.
So you've basically paid
200% return
to hedge out
sector risk.
Which is a lot to pay.
So it's a bit subjective,
but that
has underperformed
the consumer discretionary sector.
So that is the best trade.
Does that make sense?
Now how do you know this
at the beginning?
You don't.
You've just got to go through
the processes
and try and work out
what you want to be exposed to,
why you want to be exposed to it
and do your best
to outperform the market
and the sector
by selecting the best stock
in the sector
or one of the best stocks
and shorting
something against it
either sector
stock
that is going to provide
a good hedge
against risk
and then
if you hedge out that risk
you'll get
effectively
you'll get good return
but if you get the home run
you'll hedge out that risk
and get the return.
top down process
recap
obtaining a view
on the market
by using the leading indicators
getting a view
on the sector
by analysing the value chain
so you've got to start
I would advise you
to start with two sectors
map them all out
on the value chain
just write down
get a pen and paper
write down
where all the stocks
where the companies lie
on the value chain
learn the sector
learn what the companies do
decide whether the sector
is going to outperform
or underperform the market
if you're bullish on GDP
you're going to have
a predisposition
to cyclicals
so your view on cyclicals
is going to be
well if I'm bullish on GDP
by default
I think cyclicals
are going to outperform
that's not difficult
the more difficult process
is going through
the companies
within the sector
and finding
which ones you think
are going to massively
outperform both
the sector
and the market
because they're the guys
that have got
the operating plan
which is superior
to everybody else's
in the sector
but there's ways
to identify it
which we do now
when we go through
the sector
the stock level
and at the same time
you've got to decide
and this is subjective
because it's
also in the context
of what your portfolio
looks like
at the time
so for example
your
query there
about
exposing yourself
too much
to one thing
in your sector
this is the last part
which is
what risk
do I actually
want to accept
and expose myself
to in this trade
however that's
subjective
to what your portfolio
looks like
at the time
because if you've got
a really really
risky portfolio
at the time
that's a personal
situation
no one can give you
the guidance
on that here
you've got to
then understand
whether in the
context of that
situation
you can take
more risk
or not
so there's a
risk profile
of the different
types of trades
that you can use
in an attempt
to outperform
the market
and the sector
so if you've just
got exposure
to the index
where you're just
buying or selling
the S&P 500
you've got market
risk, sector risk
and stock risk
now your stock
risk shouldn't
be significant
but throughout
history there's
examples of where
it could be
and one's
happened recently
who can tell me
one that's happened
recently in the
S&P 500
why if you owned
the S&P 500
one stock
could actually
ruin your year
in the middle
of last year
what was the
weighting of
Apple in the
S&P 500
4%
what was the
weighting of
Apple in the
middle of last
year
of Nasdaq
so what's
happened to
Nasdaq over
the S&P 500
in the last
seven months
it's underperformed
that's an
example of
owning an
index
like the
Nasdaq 100
and having
significant
exposure to
one stock
this is one
of the reasons
why people
were selling
Apple
this is
what people
don't understand
people look at
Apple and go
well they make
nice phones
and they look
cheap
no one cares
they just don't
want the exposure
in the portfolio
so they dump
them
that's one
reason why
we're going to
go through
Apple a bit
later
it's a very
good example
so I'm
going to send
you spreadsheets
with some
spread trade
examples
the stuff that
we did here
where we're
downloading this
data again
publicly available
it's all just
daily stock
data from
Yahoo Finance
you download
you download it
you draw the
charts
you map
your sector
out on your
value chain
and you start
working out
why things are
moving the way
they're moving
and go and
discover the
operating plans
of companies
within the
sector
and start
deciding who
you want to be
exposed to
why you want
to be
exposed to
it
what risk
you want
to be
exposed to
and how
you can
hedge that
out
and whether
it's worth
doing at
all
because if
it's not
worth doing
don't do
it
just go
and buy
the market
so you'll
get
a step
by step
PDF guide
on how
to
actually
go in
download the
data
go through
all the
steps
and identify
these trades
and how you
look at them
how you
decide
which ones
look good
don't look
so good
we use
an example
which is
long
Goldman Sachs
short
JP Morgan
and then
the sheet
that you can
use
to have a
look at
all the
sectors
in the
US
you get
as well
so it's
a full
breakdown
of all
the
sectors
in the
US
and
Europe
they've
all got
live
links
in them
and you
can
click
on them
and it
takes you
to the
sectors
on the
websites
with all
of the
valuations
okay
welcome back
I do
hope you
managed to
grasp
some of
the main
concepts
there
if you
didn't
just keep
going back
and going
over the
presentation
and just
make sure
that these
concepts
stick
so the
principle
here of
doing the
least amount
of work
possible
for the
highest amount
of return
with the
lowest amount
of risk
so how does
this all
fit in
well when we
look at
our world
view
and then we
go to the
industry level
well from
our world
view we
can easily
take a
view on the
stock market
so if we're
bullish on
GDP we
buy the
S&P 500
if we're
bearish on
GDP we
sell the
S&P 500
when we
go to the
industry level
and the
stock level
we really
don't want to
be going
long stocks
and sectors
that are going
to underperform
the stock market
otherwise we
can just
buy the
stock market
there's no
point in
going to
trade further
and deeper
into the
stock market
if we can
get as
good a
return just
trading the
market and
vice versa
if we're
bearish we
don't want to
be shorting
sectors and
stocks within
those sectors
that end up
outperforming
the market
we might as
well have just
used the
market as a
short or a
hedge
and in
this situation
when we're
going long
sectors and
stocks relative
to short
sectors and
stocks the
whole concept
here of
getting the
highest amount
of return for
the least amount
of risk really
applies because
in the hedge
fund world
what really
matters is
your risk
adjusted
return so
you'll see the
examples that
we went
through the
cross-sector
spread trades
the cross-sector
constituent spread
trades and
the intra-sector
constituent spread
trades those
examples what
you probably
noticed is that
the more risk
that you hedge
out you tend
to get a
lower return
now that's
absolutely fine
because you're
actually taking
less risk to
get that return
the home run
trade is when
you basically
hedge out as
much risk as
possible but
you get the
return that you
would have got
or get a better
return than you
would have got if
you didn't hedge
out that risk
that's the home run
trade and that's
the trade that
professional traders
are always hunting
for so
remember those
different types of
trades the cross-sector
constituent spread
trade the cross-sector
spread trade and
the intra-sector
constituent spread
trade because
these are the types
of trades that
you'll always be
looking at so
when you're bullish
on the world and
you're bullish on
a sector you've got
lots of different
trades that you can
do you can do a
cross-sector spread
trade you can look
for stocks within
the sector and do
cross-sector
constituent spread
trades you can also
do intra-sector
spread trades where
you're trading a
more cyclical stock
within the same
sector versus a
less cyclical stock
within the same
sector and if you
can go through
these processes and
go through these
levels and manage
to hedge out as
much risk as
possible and still
get a very high
return or even a
better return than
you would have got
if you didn't hedge
up those risks
doing other trades
then you've
basically hit the
home run because
over the lifetime
of that trade let's
say it's three months
if a disaster happens
in the world or
something occurs in
the sector or
the market that
makes everything go
down then your
shorts will go down
as much as your
longs and you won't
get stopped out or
won't get forced out
of the trade so
during that journey
of getting that
return if you can
take the least
amount of risk
possible and get
the highest amount
of return then
you're an extremely
efficient trader
because there's no
doubt about it as
a trader at some
point in your life
and it happens
quite regularly
you know we've
seen a lot of
situations over the
last decade 15
years where there's
an external shock
an exogenous shock
that nobody expected
in the world and
the market moves
big and if
you're taking
positions where
you're taking a
lot of risk and
you're not hedging
out for example
market risk and
sector risk you
can lose a lot of
money very quickly
whereas if you
hedge out risk you
might not lose any
money at all in
fact you might come
out of it making
money so this is a
really important
concept make sure
you get your head
around these around
this concept and
around these trades
because these are
the types of trades
you're going to be
looking at all the
time within the
stock market now
we're going to go
over to the
computer screen and
I'm going to show
you how you go
into different
websites download
data for stocks
and basically chart
and analyze spread
trades let's go
over to the
computer screen and
once you learn how
to do this it will
start to become
second nature and
then you can start
building multiple
trade ideas and
even when you have
one idea you can
build multiple
different types of
trades using the
trades that we've
looked at in order
to generate ideas
to get the most
efficient trade so
let's go through
an example on the
computer screen and
learn how to do
that and then we're
going to move on
to video 19 where
we're going to go
one step further and
we're going to start
looking at stocks so
let's go to the
computer screen and
I'll see you in
video 19.
okay so welcome to
the computer screen
now what I'm going
to show you here is
how to generate or
analyze a spread
trade and really
this is part of the
idea generation
process because what
we're going to do
here is generate an
idea and assume that
to begin with we
actually have a
world view and an
industry view and now
we're looking at
potential trades and
what we're going to
do here is actually
just use a couple of
resources and only
publicly available
information so we're
going to be using
Excel and the
internet and that's
it basically so what
we're going to do
first we're going to
go to Yahoo Finance
and what we're doing
here is we're going
to assume that we
have a world view we
have an industry view
and that our
world view is
bullish and we're
leaning towards
cyclical sectors so
we're going to be
looking at the
financial sector and
we're going to be
looking in particular
at banks so
specifically we're
going to be looking
at Goldman Sachs
and JP Morgan
and we're going to
be looking at going
long Goldman Sachs
and short JP Morgan
because Goldman Sachs
is a more cyclically
sensitive so their
earnings are more
sensitive to the
business cycle than
JP Morgan's this is
because Goldman Sachs
is a pure investment
bank and JP Morgan
is a retail bank
with an investment
bank attached to it
so first of all
we're going to look
at Goldman Sachs
and we just pull up
Goldman Sachs here
and we just go
straight to historical
prices and we just
want to download the
daily data so
Goldman Sachs data
goes back to May
4th 1999 why
because that's when
they went public
that was the IPO
so we scroll to the
bottom and we just
click download to
spreadsheet
and we have the
data come up here
open high low
close volume
and adjusted
close the one we
want is here
the adjusted
close because that
includes dividends
we just tidy that
up and we call
this GS
so that's pretty
straightforward
what we want now
is the JP Morgan
data here
in column C
so we go back
online
and
we grab
the JP Morgan
data
same process
historical prices
daily data
going back
to 1983
scroll to the
bottom
download
spreadsheet
and there's
our data
so we copy
this
and we just
go
shortcut
over
to our
spreadsheet
from earlier
and this is the
JP Morgan
data
so we
insert our
JPM data
here
and
now we
want to
create
the spread
so GS
divided by
JP Morgan
and the
convention
always is
here
the stock
that we're
looking to
go long
or the
asset
that we're
looking to
go long
always on
the top
of the
fraction
so always
the numerator
and the stock
we're looking to
go short
always on the
bottom of
the fraction
so the
denominator
and
all we
do
is divide
the
Goldman
Sachs
share
price
by
the
JP
Morgan
share
price
and we
get
3.034
now what
we're going
to do
here
is just
put this
to two
decimal
places
so we've
got 3.03
and we're
going to
autofill
all the
way down
now let's
scroll down
to the
bottom of
the data
now remember
JP Morgan
went much
further back
than Goldman
Sachs
because
Goldman Sachs
was public
on the
4th of
May
we can
see here
that on
that day
the spread
was 1.71
and now
the spread
is 3.03
so Goldman
Sachs
has
outperformed
JP Morgan
by a
very good
margin
over that
time period
and what
we're going
to do
here is
take
the data
and we're
going to
create
a chart
so we
just scroll
all the
way up
and we've
started
creating the
chart
here
now what
we've got
to do
we'll just
get rid
of this
label
here
we've got
to select
the chart
right mouse
and select
data
and we're
just going
to give
this a
name
so let's
call it
GS
JPM
and we
want to
go to
the
horizontal
axis
and we
need to
select
the
corresponding
dates
and I
like to
scroll down
just to
make sure
that we're
getting the
right dates
lined up
with the
right data
so 4th
of May
and then
we scroll
all the
way up
right to
the top
and there
we have
it
that is
our
spread
from
now I've
just selected
the dates
here
let's do
that again
selected the
dates
format
axis
and all
I'm doing
here is
tidying
up
the
chart
I'm
going to
select the
y-axis
and
I'm going
to change
the minimum
to 1
I'm going
to change
the max
to 6
and
so we
can view
this a little
bit better
I'm going
to change
the major
unit
to 0.25
and I'm
also going
to just
thin out
the line
of the
chart
so
format
data
series
line
style
and I'm
also going
to change
the colour
there we
go
so what
we're
looking at
here
is
Goldman Sachs
divided by
JP Morgan
and you
can see
right at
the beginning
in May
so this
area here
the spread
was 1.7
now it's
3.03
and when
you think of
this intuitively
it kind of
makes sense
because
US GDP
is a lot
higher than
it was
in
and
the
Goldman Sachs
as a
business
is a lot
more cyclical
in terms
of their
earnings
relative
to
JP
Morgan
so you
would
expect
the
spread
to
be
higher
what
about
everything
in
between
well
what we
can do
is actually
overlay
this
on the
business
cycle
so overlay
this
onto
GDP
growth
and or
we can
overlay
this
onto
the
ISM
we can
do that
in a
second
firstly
what I'm
going to
show you
is how
we can
add
some
technicals
onto
this
chart
so
let's
add
a
trend
line
long
term
trend
so
linear
trend
line
here
we
get
a
long
term
average
trend
line
of
the
spread
so
we
can
see
that
it's
well
below
at
the
moment
what
we
can
also
trend
line
we
can
add
on
moving
averages
so
let's
have
a
look
at
a
day
moving
average
and
we
can
change
the
colour
of
that
let's
change
that
to
green
and
we
can
also
add
on
a
longer
term
moving
average
so
let's
say
a
day
moving
average
let's
make
that
purple
so
that's
how
you
add
on
technicals
now
in
terms
of
this
spread
we
might
want
to
see
how
this
spread
behaves
in
comparison
to
the
business
cycle
so
let's
rename
this
chart
here
this
sheet
as
Goldman Sachs
JPM
and
let's
create
another
sheet
and
rename
that
GS
JPM
manufacturing
so
we want
to have
a look
at this
against
the
ISM
let's
go back
on the
internet
and
let's
google
ISM
manufacturing
and
here we
go
first
one
ISM
manufacturing
report
on
business
all
publicly
available
information
report
on
business
manufacturing
data
and
we can
get
historical
information
and we
want
all
manufacturing
indexes
in one
file
just
wait for
that to
download
to download
it's
quite a big
file
and what
we want
from this
is the
PMI data
the purchasing
managers index
so there we go
PMI
click into there
and what do we have
we've got the PMI
going back
all the way
to
so just
enable
and edit
on this
sheet
but our
spread only
goes back
to 99
so I'm
going to go
and select
everything to
May 99
and I'm going to
copy that
flick back
over to
our other
sheet
and I'm
just going to
lock that in
here
and we're
going to
call that
date
and we're
going to
call this
menu for
ISM
manufacturing
stick these
in bold
and what we
probably want
to do is
flip this
data over
so we've
got the
most recent
data at
the top
so what
we can
do is
just
filter
and we
can sort
this
newest
to
oldest
and we've
got from
March
to
May
so
what we
want to
do now
is get
Goldman Sachs
JP Morgan
and the
spread
here
so we
can start
comparing
the spread
to the
business
cycle
so what
do we
do next
well
we've got
monthly
data here
so let's
go and get
the monthly
data for
Goldman Sachs
and JP
Morgan
so we've
got JPM
here
and we
want to
change this
to
March
1st
we want
monthly
data
get
prices
oh no
apologies
we wanted
May
to
just put
that in
the wrong
column
in the
wrong
section
there
March
1st
get
prices
so we've
got this
from
March
1st
to
May
so we
download
this
into
our
spreadsheet
you can
see here
March
to
May
that's
great
exactly
what we
want
so we
just
take
all of
that
data
copy
that
and
then
dump
that
here
we
call
that
JPM
let's
just
make
sure
this
is
all
lined
up
yep
lined
up
nicely
and
now
we
want
our
Goldman
SAG
data
here
so
we
repeat
the
same
process
for
Goldman
Sachs
GS
historical
prices
May
4th
correct
and we
just
change
this
to
March
1st
we
want
monthly
data
and we
want to
get all
of that
data
copy
and we
want to
stick
that
in
here
call
that
GS
and this
is going
to be
GS
over
JPM
we
do
the
same
as we
did
earlier
Goldman
Sachs
divided
by
JP
Morgan
and we
want to
get this
to only
two decimal
places
again
and we
just
auto
fill
down
perfect
everything's
lined up
nicely
and we're
going to
draw that
chart
just get rid
of this
label
again
select
data
get the
dates
lined up
give
this
a name
so
GS
JPM
ISM
manufacturing
let's get
this
lined up
so you
get the
correct dates
in there
what we're
going to do
manufacturing
and we're
going to
select a
new
series
and we
want this
column here
column B
and we
hit enter
well that's
come up
looking a
bit odd
but it
won't look
odd for
long
in the
manufacturing
data
we want
to get
the same
dates
again
so
everything's
lined up
correctly
that's all
fine
that's
okay
that
now what
we do
is we
want to
put
the
manufacturing
data
on the
secondary
axis
so we
select the
line
format
data
series
and we
click on
secondary
axis
and you
can see
they both
come up
on the
same
chart
the
ISM
is on
the
right
hand
side
Goldman Sachs
JP Morgan
spread
is on
the
left
hand
side
so
we're
going to
tidy
this
left
hand
axis
I'm
going to
create
a
minimum
of
one
maximum
of
six
is
fine
major
unit
0.25
on the
right
hand
axis
we'll
do a
minimum
of
say
and
a
major
unit
there
when we
look a
little bit
closer
we can
start
looking at
the
behaviour
of this
spread
when
compared
to the
business
cycle
and
what you
can see
quite
clearly
is that
since
around
September
so
around
this
time
here
the
Goldman Sachs
JP Morgan
spread
has
gone
pretty much
the same
direction
all the
time
as the
ISM
beforehand
it's
questionable
you can
definitely see
in this
period
this whole
here
that
the
Goldman Sachs
JP Morgan
spread
just goes
up
whereas
the
ISM
oscillates
and
that
can
probably
be
explained
because
Goldman
Sachs
only
IPO'd
have
a
lot
to
do
with
the
IPO
price
but
certainly
since
September
we've
seen
the
ISM
explain
a lot
of
the
move
in
the
Goldman Sachs
JP Morgan
spread
now
something
else
you can
do
here
you
can
zoom
in
by
copying
your
chart
so
copy
below
and
just
change
the
dates
so
we
can
zoom
in
to
find
out
what's
been
going
on
in
more
recent
times
so
we
can
see
here
for
example
that
there's
a
double
resistance
level
at
four
and
a
half
and
since
November
Goldman
Sachs
has
been
underperforming
JP
Morgan
and
it's
been
range
bound
for
over
a
year
so
almost
going
back
to
January
what
you
can
also
do
here
is
change
the
units
so
you
get
a
better
view
of
what's
going
on
so
we
can
change
this
to
two
change
the
maximum
to
five
change
the
minor
units
the
major
units
really
what's
been
going
there's
some
momentum
here
in
that
the
day
moving
average
is
crossing
the
day
moving
average
from
below
and
this
could
mark
some
sort
of
change
in
occurrence
the
spread
which
seemed
to
occur
around
October
let's
go
back
to
the
ISM
situation
we
can
do
the
same
over
here
copy
it
below
format
axis
let's
look at
this
since
so
we'll
look at
this
during
the
subprime
crisis
as
well
now
and
let's
get
the
dates
lined
up
so
it'll
look
a bit
nicer
and
you
can
pretty
much
see
here
since
the
subprime
crisis
and
we
know
from
looking
at
the
chart
above
it
started
to
occur
around
September
that
the
ISM
explains
a lot
of the
move
in
Goldman Sachs
JP Morgan
in
terms
of
the
spread
and
a lot
of
these
processes
that
you
go
through
you
know
this
process
that
we've
just
gone
through
here
you're
going
to
be
going
through
this
process
a
lot
when
you're
generating
ideas
especially
with
spread
trades
when
you're
generating
ideas
and
building
maintaining
your
watch
list
because
imagine
if
you
had
multiple
spread
trades
here
in
the
same
file
and
you
had
all
your
ideas
in
one
file
this
is
what
we're
trying
to
do
we're
trying
to
work
smart
here
and
go
out
into
the
world
get
the
information
that's
really
relevant
interpret
that
information
correctly
and
turn
it
into
real
money
and
what
you've
just
seen
here
is
a
good
example
of
that
we've
gone
out
into
the
world
and
we've
used
publicly
available
information
we've
downloaded
data
that's
publicly
available
the
important
stuff
and
we've
started
to look
at the
relationship
between
spreads
and the
business
cycle
and the
one that
we
looked at
Goldman Sachs
JP Morgan
clearly shows
that it
follows
the
business
cycle
and
you can
use
any
leading
indicators
in this
situation
you know
I'd
encourage
you to
try this
go and
have a
look at
consumer
sentiment
and
have a
look at
consumer
sentiment
overlaid
onto
retail
stocks
have a
look at
building
permits
numbers
have a
look at
building
permits
overlaid
onto
housing
stocks
and
have a
look at
spreads
where you
can
hedge
out
market
and
sector
risk
like we
have done
here
in this
spread
so don't
forget
this
spread
Goldman Sachs
over JP
Morgan
we're actually
in the process
of looking at
this if we
actually put
this trade
on
we're hedging
out both
market and
sector risk
and we're
still getting
amazing returns
so imagine
if you
were here
somewhere
and it's
the beginning
of GDP
growth out
of the
O2
recession
and you
were looking
at Goldman
Sachs
JP Morgan
well
let's say
you managed
to get
this spread
on at
three
at the
peak of
the bull
market
you might
have got
out of
this spread
around five
so that's
200 points
over
300 points
so that's
a good
66%
return
but over
that entire
time period
you've actually
hedged out
all of that
risk
so you
can go
and get
other leading
indicators
have a look
at
consumer
sentiment
have a look
at ISM
non-manufacturing
have a look
at building
permits
get all of
the leading
indicator data
it's all
publicly
available
and start
generating
trade ideas
now we'll
see later
the next
step
are processes
that you
go through
in order
to
build
manage
and maintain
your watch
lists
and you're
going to have
multiple ideas
on your watch
list
remember
an idea
is only
to this
stage
we still
have to
time
our trades
through
technicals
and price
action
and we'll
be showing
you that
later
in
other videos
so that's
it from
the computer
screen
that's how
you
basically
generate
and chart
your trade
ideas
to get an
appreciation
and understanding
of their
behaviour
and let's
move on
to the next
video
and I'll
see you
there
Thank you.